[Music]
all right all right all right how we
doing
[Applause]
folks all right I feel that energy I
know you guys might be a little damp
welcome to everyone coming in sorry for
the craziness that's Tennessee weather
this just how it is give it five minutes
it'll change all right um but guys
welcome so much thank you thank you
thank you to all of you guys here in the
room if you can make some noise and say
hi to everybody that's watching online
in our live stream come
[Applause]
on the millions upon millions that are
tuning in to be a part of this
incredibly special occasion for us to
celebrate Dr John delone launching an
incredible
[Applause]
book we know how to party nothing says
mental Wellness like you're worth being
well Koozie right this speaks volume
there says right on brand right there
hey uh I don't have a whole lot to cover
with you guys before I bring John out
but I just want you to know this night
is so so special and it's not just about
the amount of work that has gone into
this The Blood Sweat tears prayers
everything snot farts all that stuff
that has made this happen but really
what this signifies the start of which
is a lot of people hearing about Hope
and getting the help that they need I
know that so many of us are in this room
today and so many of us are watching
online because we've experienced that in
our own lives we've seen a glimmer of
hope in spaces that maybe felt dark for
a long time we've seen how somebody got
us and was able to put into words
something that we had trouble
articulating for far too long and that's
the beauty of being in this space
together so we get to celebrate that and
Mark that off and send that off so that
in this world there could be another
light that is bright to shine in the
darkness does sound good to you guys
tonight all right
so this is how this is going to go we're
going to bring out John in just a second
he's going to go off the rails as John
does we're going to have a lot of fun
there's instruments here there's
confetti no it's not confetti cannons
there's who knows what's going to happen
tonight we're going to have a blast and
the best way for us to maximize our time
is to really pump him up and laugh extra
loud at his jokes and to gasp really big
when he says things that are
inappropriate sorry and all of that
stuff so let's let's actually let's just
give it a practice tonight let me hear
like a good just like 5 .5 laugh in the
room let me hear that real
quick see that's a good like middle of
the ground now let's hear like a really
big laugh like over the top
laugh yeah see that that's what I'm
looking for those lives right there
where it's like everything's quiet and
it's
just perfect perfect now can we uh can
we get just like a a normal like
applause let's try that real
fast yep that's that's a normal one he
just sunk a putt on uh par five there
now let's let's get like a big Applause
like who my gosh you just said
something all right hopefully we can
dial that up just a couple more notches
because I am done talking I am done
filling up this time we've got this room
filled primed and ready to welcome and
Usher into this night something so so
special I am so excited for you guys to
be here I'm so grateful that we filled
this room to really honor this man that
has poured heart and soul into this
project into this work so would you
please welcome to the stage Dr John
delone let's
go
hey
[Applause]
what's up what are we
doing what are we
doing
ah what are we
doing you did you came to a book A book
signing in a punk rock show broke out
and I'm super glad that you're
here I can't even wrap my head around
this I I told the the VIP group earlier
I mean I was set that uh I was going to
walk in they said hey we sold out of the
tickets I was going to walk in and my
mom was going to have bought all of them
and be like
hey and then I texted today I like hey
Mom I got a thing and she's like you
have a what I was like okay
pH um so I grew up in Houston Texas and
yep
and I grew up on uh three Pines Drive
and the street is so important to me I
have it tattooed on my body twice right
and there was lots of guys on the street
and they were uh it's one of those
streets it's magic it's just full of
kids everywhere there's kids everywhere
and there were Christian kids and
atheist kids and some Mexican-American
kids and some Asian-American kids and
some I don't know kids and young kids
and some older kids and then their
parents were this mix of like bankers
and accountants and Military folks and
and pastor and all across the Spectrum
but amidst that crew there was a
gang it was me and Ryan and Chris that
we called putts and Caleb me and Ryan
putts and Caleb and when I say ride or
die I mean the guys were my ride or die
we would wrap houses together how many
of you used to toilet paper
houses now everyone's got a ring camera
and so that's
dead
one time we annihilated this guy's house
and when I say annihilated it was like I
as we drove away running away I remember
like having a tinge of high school like
that's not cool man like we demolished
it and then the next morning at like 8:
a.m. he was an attorney and I opened the
door and I was like oh gosh and he goes
hey do you still mow Lawns and I was
like yeah and he goes somebody destroyed
my house last night can I pay you to
clean it up and I was like yes you can
we me and Ryan P kill we dated some of
the same girls which got weird right um
we would play hide and go seek we would
play hide-and go seek at 11:00 at night
and we would have a game called roof
hide-and go seek where we would have to
hide and get each other on other
people's roofs and now that I'm a
grown-up one yeah yeah now everybody's
armed in America back then it was like
okay okay so one
time I I promise this is Ryan's idea
there was a fence and then there was a
like a thoroughfare Street and then
there was a yard and then a fence and we
were behind this fence and they got the
great idea that if we tied some fishing
line around this fence and pulled it
into the middle of the
street and they had a like uh a
Tasmanian devil stuffed animal and they
tied it to one arm then they tied fish
on line to this arm and then we went
behind the fence over here at midnight
and then we just
waited and then imagine this is you
you're driving down the road and your
four beers in just trying to get
home I'm looking at you sir I'm just
kidding I'm
talking and all of a sudden as the car
is driving the lights get brighter and
brighter the guys go okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay and then you just
slowly pull the fish in line and in the
middle of the street this Tasmanian
Devil
[Music]
goes and as a kid we learned there's two
kinds of people there's the kind of
person that Slams on their brakes and
goes oh my there's a floating Tasmanian
devil in the middle of street and
there's the other person that was
probably eight beers I'm looking at you
just go right and hits it um to tell you
about how these guys are like who they
are
right after we graduated uh putts and
Caleb got an apartment together and they
pulled their pennies and they bought um
a 1987 Lexus with 300,000 miles on it
and I asked him why'd you get a Lexus
and one of them goes girls dude girls
300,000 miles no air conditioner Houston
Texas they shared a one-bedroom
apartment and it was 2: a.m. and they
were pulling in and they tell the story
so specifically because um Welcome to
the Jungle was playing so they're two
dudes thinking they're cool and another
car is they're waiting for the car to
drive by and the car turns this way and
all of a sudden a guy gets
out and he runs over to the car put
Chris's driving and he shoves a gun into
the passenger side into Chris's face and
he says give me your
wallet now there's a wallet right here
come to find out inside that wallet was
s
cents I'll say that again seven
cents the government had long taken
their driver's
license and so instead of
going
okay Chris
froze and Caleb who's about this
big you ask him he what were you doing
he's like I don't know man that wasn't
good at all he snapped he said he opens
the door and
runs around the car screaming at this
guy hey no and the way they describe it
is the guy had a pulled the car over put
the gun in was like give me your wallet
and all of a sudden this little guy is
running around screaming and he's going
like this like this and he said by the
time the guy realized oh he's coming
after I've got the gun he said by the
time he realized to do this to Caleb
Caleb form tackled him in the middle of
the street at 2: a.m. and begin
screaming do not Point guns at my
friends like
that to which the guy was humongous
Caleb was not he easily rolled Caleb
over and tossed him and Caleb had
decided tonight this guy has to die so
he hung onto him like this and the guy
started hitting him with the gun Caleb
won't let go so then the guy drags Caleb
into the car and starts driving slamming
Caleb's arm arms in the in the car
dragging him down the road now when
they're telling me this this is when I
was like whatever guys you're an idiots
this didn't happen and Caleb goes like
this he pulls his shirt up and it is
road rash all the way down and I was
like oh gosh tell me then what happened
right and so they the guy takes off and
he's getting dragged down the car I mean
down the road guy slamming his arm in
the door until finally he lets go and at
this exact moment Chris is like oh my
gosh he comes too and the car is driving
off and he looks and Caleb's gone and
putts things to his head oh no they
stole Caleb to which he hammers the gas
as hard as he can
goes driving right past Caleb who's
laying right by the
curb and Caleb says he like kind of gets
up I was like a whole thing happens so
fast and he sits on the curb he's like
oh man Chris on the other hand is
driving as fast as he can and he can't
catch this car and he's terrified and he
thinks they they've kidnapped my friend
they've kidnapped my friend and he
panics and he starts smashing that car
with his
car in the road Too Fast Too Furious
style and the way he tells it is they
kind of ran came came off a main road
onto the highway and he went for one big
swoop and he missed and he hits a
minivan that's just minding their own
business and the car totals and ends up
in the field Caleb get I mean Chris gets
out he's bloody his car is a wreck
there's another car over here and he
goes for you younger kids before you had
cell phones there used to be these
things called pay phones and he goes
over to the pay phone and puts a quarter
in and he calls Caleb's mom and says I
don't know how to tell you this but your
son just got kidnapped and they headed
off into downtown Houston if you go to
downtown Houston it's like a swamp it's
it's over right police are called they
search all night no
Caleb so Chris gets a ride home they
have to tow the car out the whole
thing's total he has no car which he has
no girls now
clearly he gets home and he's the way he
describes it he said man I was walking
into my
apartment I lost my friend lost my car
he's bleeding shouldn't have been
driving now he's going to have to deal
with the law and he opens up the door
and he
said Caleb is sitting in there on the
couch with his feet on the coffee table
and goes what up dude where you
been these guys would go to hell in back
for their friends that's what I grew up
with I love these guys and we've had
years where we didn't talk to each other
we've all grown up we're all old now we
got kids and families and our lives are
different but I love these guys I talked
to them last night I love these
guys so I was 12 years old and I was
sitting in my dad's recliner and I was
watching this thing um we used to call
it uh MTV and for your young kids MTV
used to be a channel where hold your
hold your breath they played music on it
before they ruined America with reality
TV which they invented but they used to
play songs over and over and I was
sitting in my dad's recliner and the
single greatest song ever written came
on by the single greatest band of all
time and I know some of you in this room
are like Oh The Beatles
really Metallica
Halen
artha Adele the stones Drake No you're
all
wrong I'll give you artha and rund
DMC maybe EPMD Johnny Cash the greatest
band of all time in the history of human
existence is the
legendary hair metal Quattro called
Poison and I sat in that recliner and
this song called Something to Believe In
came on and I remember getting
Goosebumps and my sister was was on the
couch she's here tonight my sister was
on the couch and I remember watching
this it was the most amazing thing I'd
ever seen I couldn't believe
this she got up when it was over and I
was like and she literally goes that was
so stupid and she walked into she but I
was like oh how could any band write a
song that powerful that hits my soul
like that and then two years later I
used to go to this music studio at my
friend's Jason's house his dad had owned
a music studio where kids took lessons
and we would go there and we would learn
how to play Patience by Guns and Roses
or To Be With You by Mr Big and I didn't
know how to play guitar so he would just
teach me the next chord that I needed to
learn we played um uh uh uh uh Every
Rose Has Its Thorn and then the talent
show came and he's like let's do a song
and I was like Let's Do Something to
Believe In and he he was like oh yeah he
played guitar I had a white dress shirt
and on the outside of it I had a pokka
outed dress shirt and I looked
amazing but we saying Something to
Believe In and that was the first time
in my life I got a standing ovation and
it was a drug it was like in the vein I
remember thinking I need more of
this and I fell in love with learning
how to play guitar and I fell in love
with learning how to communicate on
stages and I fell in love with trying to
figure out how to take these big
Universal truths and write a big song
that me meant the world and Something to
Believe In is like a song it explores
these really deep topics that I didn't
realize at the time but it talks about
like profound loss and it talks about
Christian leaders not acting like Christ
out in the out in the world and it talks
about income inequality and questioning
God during hard times and I just thought
these dudes had great abs and could wo
and they had motorcycles man they looked
awesome fast forward 10 years later and
I can't tell you the number of times I
drove the dusty plains of Texas going
back and forth to
college cuz I thought my mom was sick
cuz I was going to see my sister who I
love more than life
itself I was so anxious I couldn't
breathe sometimes there was Seasons when
my wife was asleep and we were newly
married and we owed so much money I
couldn't breathe and I don't know how
she could sleep I don't think she knew
and I would I remember being in my own
living and I would drive and I would say
God give me something to believe in and
in a weird way this '90s pop metal act
these dudes who put on more makeup than
anybody should be
wearing had created this liturgy these
four Dudes from Pennsylvania who went to
Hollywood created this l lurgical
refrain for
me and then I graduated college and Ryan
got a double major so he stayed one more
year and the week after graduation his
buddy ran a stop sign and
boom and me and Ryan I mean me and Caleb
and Chris and a couple other friends we
went to Austin I was a high school
teacher at the time and we went to
the the ICU waiting room
and we slept on the floor for several
days and I used a shoe as a
pillow and we would go to Denny's and we
would come back and we'd go to Denny's
and we'd come back and I remember one
night we were all laying there heads
down on a on a
shoe Caleb here Chris here crying moms
doctors
busy Caleb just started singing Give Me
Something to Believe In yeah when we all
started singing it real quiet while our
buddy our brother his life hung in the
balance this fast forward 20
years building a non-anxious
life so I wrote own your past change
your future and it went to number one
it's the number one book in the country
I remember I was driving in a car in a
in a we were at a book signing in Dallas
and Preston Canon who's here the best
publishing guys on the planet Earth he
hands his phone back behind him he's in
the front seat and he hands it back and
it just said number one and I was like
all right and instantly Dave Ramsey
calls I answer the phone he is screaming
you did it I'm like oh I did it
right so when it came time to sit down
with a publishing team about book number
two I me I'm a freaking number one
bestselling author I get to tell them
what I'm going to write and they were
like hey you wrote a book about anxiety
a little bitty pamphlet book by the way
my daughter's um here somewhere and my
wife is an author and she wrote a great
book my son is is a writer and he wrote
a book that we had
bound and my daughter was talking about
how famous my wife is and I was like I I
wrote a book I'm
famous and she was like no no dad and I
went I literally went and got it I got
that little skinny pamphlet book and I
was like look and she goes that's not a
book dad and like
ah but they said that book sold like
crazy and I don't care so much about
Book Sales but that meant a whole bunch
of people read it and finally said for
once thank God someone's not talking
over me they said this in a way that I
can actually understand it and give it
to my 14year old or to my 20- year old
or whatever so the team said the world's
really anxious we want you to write a
book on anxiety and I said I don't want
to do it I'm done talking about anxiety
I'm anxious about talking about anxiety
I'm I'm through with it I want to write
a book on parenting I want to write a
book on
adult friendship because I I'm terrible
at that I'm just done with
this so I put my foot down I'm not
writing
this then they said you're going to
write a book on anxiety and I was like
okay let's write a book on anxiety so I
lost I sulked I whed I was dramatic I
was a baby about it and I just couldn't
get the energy to dig in but I gave it a
shot and here was the central premise
what if what if what if what
if what if all the anxiety
and the burnout and the frustration and
the anger and that
rage what if it's
right what if your body's
right what if there's nothing wrong with
you at
all what if it's right what would that
mean for this insane World we've created
for
ourselves what if your body's working
perfectly what questions would we have
to ask it's so easy just to go to a
mechanic and be like I don't know what's
wrong with this thing plug it in give me
a diagnosis a diagnostic on this thing
and then just fix it it's way harder
when the mechanic comes out and sits at
a table and goes um you're a terrible
driver you have to change the way you
drive and all of the roads that you go
on in fact can I just have your keys
right it's way
harder and so I wrote about building a
life that isn't so spun up in a world
that is freaking demanding that
everything gets spun up and I've written
two books I've written two dissertations
I've written academic papers
forever but when I sat down and start
writing this book I couldn't I couldn't
get
there it was killing
me I wasn't the dad I wanted to be at
the time who is I wasn't the husband
that I wanted to be at the time who is
and I didn't feel good about how I
looked i' started skipping one workout
which led to skipping another workout
which led to me like doing 50 workout
right in a row to crush it and then I
would get so sore I couldn't wipe
properly for like 3 weeks and I'd have
to quit working
out and I stopped
sleeping and then I started
netflixing then I started like I'm so
proud of the fact that I took Ambien for
so many years and I haven't touched that
crap in a decade but then I started
taking so many supplements I was just
starting to slowly just go
unconscious but I'm a disciplined and
hard-headed guy so I kept plugging along
and plugging along and kept pushing and
I kept getting angrier and I kept
getting more frustrated and I kept
getting more and more mad and I was
co-hosting the Ramsey Show and I was
doing the the John delone show and I was
traveling all over the place and I was
sitting with companies and I was
speaking on stages and I was all over
the place everywhere all the time and
then there was a holy moment in my
garage between me and my wife and she
said in a moment of exhausted
vulnerability
I feel like I'm watching my husband die
right in front of me and I feel like
you're cheering the whole
way and I didn't know what to say to
that but I saw the In Her Eyes the look
of exhaustion and I knew it cuz I'd seen
it before and the final moment came when
my wife secretly flew up two of my
greatest friends on planet
Earth and they surprised me on the show
I came out to sign autographs and these
two big goofballs they're two of my best
friends on the planet one is named Todd
and one is named fat John I was hyper
John he was there was only three of us
and there was two of us were John we had
to delineate right and so these two guys
come lumbering out and it was this and
my first thought was not yes my first
thought was dude I don't have time for
them to be
here and I remember thinking this is not
the way it's supposed to be so we hung
out for 48 hours and then I left I went
to a hotel and I check myself into a
hotel which isn't weird when I write I'm
hard to be around um I'm all over the
place but this time I went to a hotel
and I wasn't
okay and I realized I had a
half-finished manuscript and I realized
I didn't want to write about
anxiety because I wasn't living any of
the things I was writing about I was a
fraud and as the greatness M TB says if
you see fraud and don't say fraud you're
a fraud I was a
fraud I didn't want to write a book
about anxiety because I was living a
very anxious life from my family and
I've got two kids that are my lungs that
I can't breathe when they're not around
and my wife had been down this road
before with me and she'd seen me so
anxious and burned out of my mind and
she'd watch me almost lose everything
and when I say lose everything I mean I
almost lost
everything and here I was again in a
hotel surrounded by books and academic
journals and trash food and I began to
ask myself wait a minute what if your
body's
right what if you're not
crazy what if you're not uh what if your
body's
right what would that
mean what if my body's telling me the
truth and anxiety is just an alarm and
so I'm surrounded by Flames but I can
see through the smoke and I want to see
my friends and I'm so exhausted I want
this just to stop but what if I kept
going through the smoke towards the fire
and so I started writing and I started
backing up and I started calling a few
friends that I know making me go like
this and I
left with a pretty good road
map and then I started a renewed promise
to myself and around that time I had two
extraordinary conversations one with Mr
Lewis how and if you don't listen to the
school of greatness podcast um he's
pretty remarkable guy behind closed
doors and one with a serendipitous
coffee conversation I had with a great
man named Jeffrey Wilson in New York
City and after those two conversations
and after my wife's subtly nudging about
48 times oh maybe you should go see a
counselor and I'm like but I'm a genius
so I don't need
to yeah maybe you should go see a
counselor I'm like people call me I'm
good maybe you should go see a counselor
maybe you should listen to the John
delone show and learn a few
right
I did and I said some things out loud
that I've never said before in my entire
life and I had this draft and then I
brought it back and with lots of
help a very wise leader Daniel and Cody
and Dave and Jeremy and Suzanne and the
Great and Powerful Chris peers the
editor and Rachel and Eva all of a
sudden this thing was born and we got
this it's a road map out of an anxious
life these choices that I make every day
and whenever I say that people say like
oh so I'm just choosing to be an I'm
choosing burnout oh real cool dude
thanks for that no none of us are
actively choosing
anxiety but I chose not to take care of
my body
yesterday and I chose when I got like
this to walk away from my wife instead
of leaning back in said I'm
sorry and I chose to make my life so
chaotic that I'm late everywhere all the
time to everything forever and ever amen
I chose these things to fill my calendar
to the brim and I chose to drive around
and our bodies are screaming at us all
the time and some of these choices are
going to come easy what we found is for
most people two of these are pretty
simple two of these are like w that's
tough and two of these are like that's
impossible you're crazy I'm not doing
that do you do drugs right
and for
me I've been choosing reality for a long
time it's not hard it's fine like this
is the state of
things freedom I like that journey I
don't like going people money that one's
easy mindfulness I've been practicing
that for a decade since I run in with a
monk health and healing I'm figuring
that one out belief is hard for me bel's
hard for
me but I'll tell you the one that haunts
me is connection choosing connection
and I've got friendships that are 40
plus years old I've got guys in my life
that my wife flies
in those guys that I grew up on three
Pines they had a a loss of one of their
friends last night and they called at
12:00 in the
morning yet so often I turn inward and
I'm given to these voices of loneliness
and despair and I can be lonely in a
crowded room I can be lonely at a table
surrounded by people that I know love me
and we know that when we get lonely our
bodies go bananas and there's
no mental health and physical health and
emotional health or spiritual health
when we're lonely our bodies go
berserk and I found myself fighting for
my
life and I say that over and over I'm
fighting for my life I'm fighting for my
life and 20 years ago I met a great
friend
when I moved to Nashville he was one of
only two guys I knew in the
city and he's a really famous singer
songwriter please welcome Mr G Brooks
I'm just kidding it's not
that's that have been so awesome that
been so
cool I called gu and I got visited by
the FBI they're like you got to stop we
got to stop
calling
but my friend uh wrote a
song and I became a refrain that I sang
over and over and over again and I was
going to read the lyrics to You and I
thought it'd be even cooler so if you'll
please welcome one of my closest friends
in the world and one of the great um
Nashville singer songwriters please
welcome Mr Eric
[Applause]
Peters
they showed up that's awesome too many
piics excuse me hello
two I bought Alexus
once
[Music]
in a little while in a little
while the ghost return to
noise but not right now no not right now
the sky must be en
Joy I'm
fighting I'm fighting for I'm fighting
for my
life I'm
fighting I'm fighting for I'm fighting
for my
life another way is there any way
to
multiply our
ears but here to stay I am here to stay
cuz my eyes are bright and
clear oh I'm
fighting I'm fighting for I'm fighting
for my
life oh I'm
fighting I'm fighting
for I'm fighting for my
[Music]
life like a secret hope that is forcing
me
[Music]
awake dust and
quiet break the
ground that I have
claimed where I'm I'm
fighting yes I'm fighting for my
life I'm
fighting I'm fighting for I'm fighting
for my life oh I'm
for my
life
oo oh
[Music]
oh
oh I go into the darkness I'm carrying
the lights I will have no fear because
I'm not alone I I've got angel voices
and friends who love me for who I
am so when the waters come I'll
Fly Above This flooded Earth and I'm
looking for a sign of life and I
relocate on bows of Hope like a living
Soul remember in that in a hit a little
wall hit a little
wall the ghost return
[Music]
noise not right now no not right now the
sky must be in
[Music]
joy
thank you thank
you so let's go back 23
years
um Ryan
lived Against All Odds he made it and
um he's still hard to understand he
can't walk on his own still to this day
but man it's uncomfortable when we're
all out eating and he
pulls the shirt of the waitress and she
leans over his wheelchair and she says
hey man what's up and he goes these guys
keep hitting me
right
and almost as devastating as the
wreck it's poison broke
up I never saw him play live and then in
1999 2000 CC DeVille rejoined the band
and they announced a worldwide tour with
all the old 9s bands it was poison with
special guest warrant and rat and
trickster and Bullet Boys all of them
and it was in Houston in August it was a
th000
de and I'd been dating this woman for
like four years and we'd broken up and I
was dating somebody else and I was like
she's the one and so I was like hey
there's this um basically a huge
religious service that we're going to go
to and she was like okay and we
went and it started at 3:00 in the
afternoon and we both wore Den
in Houston in
August it was hot and by the time poison
came
on this Outdoor
Show they played the same set that they
always played and when Something to
Believe In came on I stood up and she
stood up and I looked at
her I think she's
yawning and I said hey and she goes oh
my gosh this is so boring can we
go I am not lying to you we broke up
shortly
thereafter and the next
year um it was a once in a lifetime the
band got back together and was like this
is it it's going to be amazing and the
next year poison was like dude we love
having money in a checking account let's
run it again so they came back and that
woman I'd been dating for 40 years
and I'd broken up we are now back
together and Ryan was out of his
traumatic brain injury stay and he could
go out and we got
tickets so me and Ryan and put and
Caleb
went and I broke the cardinal rule and I
brought a
girl and
the piano part we're sitting on the lawn
at Woodland's Pavilion and the piano
part starts playing to Something to
Believe In and we stood up and Ryan
couldn't stand up on his
own and so we got under one arm and then
another guy got under his other arm and
we lifted him up out of the chair and
then I held another Buddy's arm and all
four of us were standing there singing
at the top of our lungs just give me
something to believe in this song that
had woven through our friendship in our
lives for 30 years and at some point I
look
back and she's
crying I was like my God bring a girl to
a poison
show I was like
dude and so I went back and I was like
are you okay what's wrong and she said
and I
quote I can't tell you how amazing it is
to see you and these guys you love so
much being together and having this much
fun and I married
[Applause]
her in 21 years we're still hanging in
there will you please welcome for the
first time ever the original Dr delone
my wife
[Applause]
here
she she's real she's real
um oh yeah sorry um this to me so what
we want to do now is just take 3 or four
minutes and I want you to tell them why
I'm so wonderful go ahe
I'm just kidding don't do that don't do
that don't do that I have better idea
don't do that oh you do yeah no what who
wants to play Truth or Dare
no we can't do that that's was too much
20 years is a long time yeah we can both
play that game back and forth
um as you can probably imagine um being
married to me is very hard it's hard I'm
I'm as she says I'm a lot I'm a lot and
um I love yall hear me say this if you
listen to the show I say this all the
time I love what EST Perell
says is every
season whether it's something hard that
happens whether it's one of y'all does
something that hurts the other person
whether you have a kid whether you lose
a kid whether you lose a parent you have
these Seasons she said when the Twin
Towers fell down in New York City on
September 11th you couldn't go back on
September 12th and sweep up all the
glass and dust and steel and wood and
rebuild those Towers they
fell you have to build something
new or you have to walk away and let
nature take it
back and she said if you're committed to
being
married maybe you have to get some
professionals to help you build
something an architect you have to get
some people to help cultivate that site
and clear it out but you got to build
something new and the original Dr
deloney Who by the way is an
embarrassing better writer than I am
it's shameful it's shameful and she's
thinking I know I
know um thank you for always rebuilding
with me always you're welcome I'm proud
of you and your book Thank You
books yeah I like
plural um I don't know if I've ever said
this but this is my public apology for
something I said recently I don't know
if I've told this on the show or not I
hope I haven't but if I have please just
be cool I'm super
curious so and
worried I opened the
drawer um and it was full of
socks yeah and so I looked back at her
and I was like you're so
amazing like I can't do any of this
stuff without you and you're smarter
than me and you're a better writer than
me and you're more accomplished than me
and you gave up that so that I can do
this so that we can do
this and then socks are in my drawer
there's underwear in here and she said
isn't it
amazing when you open the drawer and the
sock fairy just comes and put socks in
there and when the underwear fairy just
comes and puts in there and without even
thinking I said yeah and isn't it great
when the direct deposit fairy just puts
money in the
I'm
sorry you can't go back you can just ree
Bill
hey I love
you
um I told um you can go I know this just
you're you're good I told um that next
day after I did that I was telling I was
on the Ramy show with Dave and I was
like you know what I said yesterday
thank you we give Dr thank
you
I I said um I told that to Dave and he
he goes he just put his face in his
hands and rubbed his head real hard and
he looked at me and he
goes Are you seriously my marriage
guy that's
[Applause]
awesome but when
you are committed to
rebuild
and this happens by the way in your
friendships how many of you lost
friendships during Co cuz one of you
said something one of you tweeted
something one of you had an opinion
about something it happens in your
romantic relationships it happens with
your family it happens with your kids it
happens with your neighbors it happens
and it happens and it happens and you
have to say I'm going to rebuild and
when you decide I'm going to rebuild
you're committing to one thing
hope this could work
out and every step of the way in our
culture the world tells you but it might
not but we're willing to go it might and
if you know me really well my friends
know I'm pathological I'm a psycho about
new years's I love this idea dude you
can be with a group of
friends on January I mean on December
29th like how's it going and you're like
man I've been doing a lot of cocaine and
I killed nine people but like I got my
New Year's resolutions and everyone's
like cool man
sweet in the United States we just give
everybody a mulligan on whatever you did
last year like no res I resolutions man
and like sweet no more murder # no kill
like what I don't know what you do and
so we get so excited about
it and then of course cuz this is what
songwriters
do they worm there they listen and they
say things in a
way that you go
yeah
yeah so if you'll do me a favor singing
his song about Hope singing his song
about what if what if it goes
right please welcome back my good friend
Mr Eric
[Applause]
Peters
thank
you I don't need
[Music]
that John I'm so proud of you we've
known each other for 20 plus
years um we did a tour together John
plays music played um we played some of
the crappiest shows you can ever imagine
uh
we got paid with a a flat of water
bottles for one of our shows that was
our actual payment so tour in a really
awful van so what a dude um I've heard
all the
stories not all of them
but um I'm really proud of him and um
I'm just grateful like as a person who's
uh forced to not forced it was a choice
to go get therapy see a counselor years
ago um and it's it's just a humbling
thing to admit especially for men to
admit that we need help um but that was
me a few years ago and
um but I'm just so grateful for his
voice that the fact that you're here
means that he whatever he's saying
resonates with you and I'm really
grateful that uh that this stuff is
being talked about uh mental health
um this song um this is a song about the
new year and about hope
um there's some o O's at the end of the
song I don't know if am I allowed I'm
going to get you to
sing you look like you
sing uh it's one vowel it's just o it's
the only thing you got to know um and
I'm a terrible coach uh but I'll try to
like give a kick or something uh like
poison would do
so thanks for uh thanks for listening to
me this is called the new
year
[Music]
this is the year when something changes
but nothing ever
does this is the year
when all my failures turn into a pile of
dust see this is the year when all oh my
goodness excuse me a
second
it's been a while since I've been in
front of
people speaking of
anxiety thanks for not throwing fruits
and vegetables at
me thank
you see if I can start from the from the
beginning this is the year when
something changes but nothing ever
does well this is the year when all my
failures they turn into a pile of
dust this is the year when all Fallen
faces we learn we're not
enough this is the year to hold each
other
up W it's a new
year oh oh it's a brand new light oh can
you believe it it's the skies that we
dream
[Music]
of this is the year when laughter douses
charred and burnout
dreams this is the year when Ren return
to nest in storm blown
trees is this the year of
relocation from bows of old
despair this is the year to perch on
hopes
repair W it's a new
year oh it's a brand new light oh can
you believe it it's the skies that we
dream
of well I was pale and weary
sad tired of ghost
debates a slave to voices old and vile
bitter bones in the
grave but this is the
year it's the year that something
changes this is the year it's the year
that something
Chang
Angels oh it's a New Year wo it's a
brand new light oh oh can you believe it
it's the skies that we dream of oh oh oh
it's a new year oh oh oh it's a brand
new light oh oh can you believe it it's
the skies that we dream of wo
wo oh oh
oh oh
oh it's a new year that's the part you
want to try it here we go on to wo
wo wo wo
oh oh
oh it's a new year let's do it again W
[Music]
wo it's a new
year
[Music]
thanks for singing great
[Applause]
see
and This Is
Us choosing connection we're all here
we're all
here you traveled from all over the
country some people work with me and
you're like oh I guess I'll give up my
evening to go see him again my
gosh some of you are listening to the
live stream so you're not here but for
those of you here thank you you're not
just piping the show into your ear years
while you do something else you walked
into a room into a space and you felt
the awkwardness and you felt each other
and this is how the world
changes not by clicking and thumbs
Downing everything not even by thumbs
uping
anything not from avoiding or hiding or
running or staying glued to the news
glued to the potential disaster but
being here saying hi saying please go
ahead saying you bet and connect can
begin 30 years ago 40 years ago with a
song from a bunch of dudes who used a
lot of hairspray or connection can be
romantic connection be can be born
because God dropped you on a street or
connection can begin with you're hired
connection can begin romantically like
my extraordinary Dr deloney connection
can be how many of you have heard me
tell the
story of the fateful day I walked from
my car and was walking to work and I
just stopped and I turned and I got back
in my car and I drove 3 hours away in
Texas to a city and I walked into my
buddy's office who's a medical doctor
and I said
hey I'm not okay I need somebody right
now and I didn't have an appointment and
he said bro sit down
man Jeff where are
you that's that guy right
there Dr Smith
connection can
[Music]
be we moved to Nashville and we played a
couple of little league seasons in East
Nashville with Eric and his family but
we didn't live in East Nashville so we
mov all the way out to the
woods and we're dodging meth and banjos
everywhere and we're out in the woods in
these Tennessee
Hills and I signed my son up for little
league and his coach is one of the
greatest men I've ever met a veteran and
a teacher and I write about them in the
book Mr David Browning one of the
greatest people I
know men like
that and his willingness to welcome my
family in and Johanna and Ricky and
Angela and Wes and Rachel or Cody and
Kelly and Jenna and
James and George and Jade and Dave and
it can be a love of cooking or jogging
or 80s medal choose connection when you
go
home take your kid for a walk and take a
trash sack and you'all pick up trash in
your neighborhood then y'all can hang
out and get sunshine and get exercise
and paint a picture for your neighbor of
ma what this could look like tip really
well say hello don't stare at your phone
don't Facebook your friends from high
school I know those text memes are
hilarious by the way they're
discoverable in court you should delete
some of
those one one of your friends is going
to get arrested for something and
they're going to subpoena it all and
your text messages are going to be found
out
too ask that girl out in person tell
your husband hey we need to talk tell
your wife I'm
sorry you choose Jesus cuz he's
real and your friends are going to move
your marriage will be on the verge and
then it will be on the verge again and
your kids will slam in the door and
you'll get home from deployment and
you'll get deployed and your husband
will come back and you won't be able to
breathe and your presidential candidate
won't win and you'll choose connection
and you'll go first and you'll be weird
and you'll say yes and you'll be like oh
that's so awkward but okay we'll figure
that out and you'll choose connection
not because you all hate the same people
together but because you're for the same
things
together when I'm an old old man man I'm
going to remember the
time I put my foot down and said I'm not
writing a book about
anxiety and the publishing team was like
yeah you
are and then I asked Suzanne my boss my
leader hey I would like to get everybody
in a room could we do
that and Pete said hey you're thinking
too small let's do something bigger and
I was like you're an idiot Pete that's
crazy no one will show up and then
somebody in the line says hey I flew in
from British Columbia and I was like I
don't have any friends in British
Columbia but y'all chose
connection and choosing connection is
just one of the
steps hope you enjoy the book I hope
you'll pass the book
along and if I asked you to do one weird
thing with me would you do
that okay it's going to be the only time
you ever hear me say the things I'm
about to
say will you all take out your phone and
turn on the camera I mean not the camera
all all pull out your
phone and put the light
on will yall cut these out can you do
that
now back in the 80s and90s
at a
concerts they had
lighters and we've created the wimpiest
generation in human history and this is
what we
got
okay we're for sure doing
[Applause]
[Music]
that okay you have to sing
along and here's how it goes and give me
something to believe in except that was
the wrong key it wasn't even close
wasn't even
close
[Music]
yeah you got to sway
it pretend you're as high as you would
have been that long
[Music]
ago a drive by the homeless sleeping on
a cold dark Street like bodies in an old
bone
grave and underneath the broken old neon
sign it used to read Jesus
saves I'm out of the way of the rich
folks and I see how they're living it up
and while the poor they eat from hand M
the rich drinking from the golden
C and it just makes me wonder what so
many l so you
[Music]
we and give me something to believe in
yeah there's a Lo
above and give me something to believe
in
yeah oh Lord arise
yeah you take the high road and I'll
take the low road and you take the high
road and
I I'm get me to believe in
you give me something to believe in
you sometimes I wish to God I didn't
know now things I did know
then and give me something
[Music]
to y
yeah
woo hey thank y'all for
[Applause]
wow
y
y hey let's keep it going for John
deloney come
on bearing his heart and soul out
there I'm going to say peace out to all
you guys on the live stream we're still
going to party in this room but thank
you guys for attending peace out see you
goodbye Aiden farewell so long it was
great to have you wish you could be here
it would have been super fun but you're
not I'm sorry cool I don't know what
else to say sorry it's great anyways all
right for those of us in the room we are
not done oh
no come
on a and as much as it would be within
deloney fashion to bring a whole band in
just for one half of a song that's not
what we're going to do what we want to
do tonight is we want to see